In the last class we talked about
Sherwood v Walker and were introduced,
introduced to the concept
of mutual mistake.
We learned the principle that mutual
mistake as to a basic assumption renders a
contract unenforceable.
We're going back now to look at another
case Lenawee county board of health
versus miserly.
Another case involving mutual mistake
decided by the Supreme Court of Michigan,
which the very same supreme court
which had the temerity to modernize the
standard articulated in Sherwood.
Okay.
The case involved a 600 square foot tract
of land on which three unit apartment
building also sat.
If you think about it,
600 square feet is an incredibly small
area on which to stack three apartments.
The case involves a number of sometimes
confusing conveyances concerning this
land.
A man named bloom once owned the land
and installed the septic tank on the
property without a permit and
in violation of the lender.
We county health code bloom subsequently
sold the land and the apartment to the
Messer Lee's.
The Mezzer is used the building on the
land as an income investment property,
but eventually they to sold the
land and building. This time.
The buyer was one James Barnes who also
used it primarily for income investment.
Barnes sold an acre of the property and
later offered the rest for sale when
they defaulted on their contract.
A husband and wife Mister and
missus pickles showed interest,
but we're not happy with the terms of
the contract between Barnes and messerly.
In order to allow the pickles instead to
contract directly with the Mezzer lays,
the barns is executed.
A quit claim conveying all in any of
their interests that they had in the
property back to the Mezzer Lee's
okay.
Ultimately,
the Mezzer Lee's and the pickles is
entered a $25,000 agreement for the land.
A provision of that contract
included a term that which said,
purchaser has examined this property
and agrees to accept the same in its
present condition.
There are no other and additional
written or oral understandings.
A few days later,
the new owners discovered raw
sewage seeping out of the ground.
The pickles found
themselves in a real pickle.
The Lenawee county board of health then
discovered this an adequate sewer system
and condemned the property and a permanent
injunction against human habitation
of the property until it came into
conformance with the counties sanitation
code.
This injunction was granted and the
Lenawee county withdrew from the lawsuit.
The pickles is cece pain on their land
contract and the measures Lee's filed a
cross complaint seeking foreclosure
sale of the property and a deficiency
judgment.
The pickles is counterclaimed
for rescission and filed
a third party complaint
against the Barnes is the alleged
failure of consideration and willful
concealment and misrepresentation
where the basis of this a suit,
the trial court ruled that there was
no cause of action because there was no
misrep representation.
Neither of the previous owners had known
about the septic tank and the property
was purchased as is,
but the appellate court reversed the
ruling as to the claims against the Mezzer
Hurley's determining that there was
a mutual mistake that went to a basic
element of the contract. This
miss set this mistake, concern,
quote the income producing capacity of
the property in question and the property
was in an uninhabitable and therefore
unsuitable for residential use.
The instinct court agreed
that a mutual mistake existed,
but it declined to reason within the
framework of the precedents offered by the
parties.
The Mezzer Lee's had argued that a case
a and m land development versus Miller
in 1959,
Michigan Supreme Court case dictated
that mistakes that went to the value or
quality of real estate
sold were collateral to an
agreement and did not justify
rescission.
The pickles is by contrast,
argued following Sherwood
v Walker that uh,
that a different result was dictated.
Precision was dictated and appropriate
when the parties are mistaken as to the
essence of the consideration.
Yeah.
So what kind of mistake is the
one in question in this case?
In this case, the mistake was about
the quality and value of the land,
but the court found it was also
simultaneously and materially affected,
uh,
the essence of the contractual
consideration according to the court.
Then quote,
the inexact and confusing distinction
between contractual mistakes running to
value.
And those touching the substance of
consideration serves only as an impediment
to a clear and helpful analysis for the
equitable resolution of cases in which
mistake is alleged and improving.
Accordingly.
The Holdings of a and m land development
and Shorewood with respect to material
or collateral nature of a mistake are
limited to the facts of those cases.
This is a polite way for the Michigan
Supreme Court to overrule Sherwood and am
and land a and and land or at least
overruled with regard to future disputes.
Instead,
the court look to to provisions of the
restatement of contracts which will
already looked at in the last class.
Section one 52 of the restatement advises
that where our mistake of both parties
at the time a contract was made as to a
basic assumption on which the contract
was made has a material effect on
the agreed exchange of performances.
The contract is voidable by
the adversely affected party.
First note that just because an agreement
was voidable did not mean it was
automatically void.
The court emphasized rescission
is an equitable remedy,
which is granted only in the
sound discretion of the court.
So the court need not grant rescission
in every case that a mutual mistake fell
within the language of section one 52
here the court emphasize that both parties
were innocent but more importantly for
our purposes section one 52 contained an
additional clause in less the
adversely affected party bears.
The risk of the mistake under the rule
stated in section one 54 and section one
54 provides that quote a party bears the
risk of mistake when among other things
the risk is allocated to him by agreement
of the parties had the sale agreement
allocated risk to one party.
The court determined it had it pointed
to the as is clause of the contract.
Purchaser has examined the property and
agrees to accept same in its present
condition. There are no other and
additional written or oral understandings.
This clause indicated the parties had
allocated risk regarding the present
condition of the land to the purchasers
because of this recision based on
mistake was not available
to the purchasers.
The pickles is we're stuck with a judgment
for the amount owed on their promise
to buy the contract to buy the land.
Before we finish our
discussion of mistake,
let me say a few words
about unilateral mistake.
Does contract law ever set aside
contracts if only one of the parties is
mistaken?
The answer is yes.
Section one 53 of the restatement makes
the contract voidable under the same
conditions required for voice
stability because of mutual mistake.
That is a mistake as do a basic assumption
that materially affects the agreed
upon exchange without that risk being
allocated to the mistaken party.
Those are the same kinds of conditions
that we have for mutual mistake,
but to qualify for void ability
in a unilateral mistake case,
a plaintiff must also show
one of two additional things.
Either that enforcement would be
unconscionable or that the other side had
reason to know about
the plaintiff's mistake.
There are a few important takeaways
from the Lenawee county case.
For starters,
we see the court expressly limit the
holding of Sherwood v Walker to the facts
of that case instead of
instead of following Sherwood,
the court adopted the restatements
standard for mutual mistake based on basic
assumptions.
Next,
the court emphasizes discretion in
granting contractual rescission.
Rescission is an equitable remedy and
courts need not granted if if justice
doesn't demand it.
That's important to keep in mind
when reading some of these cases.
The fact that one,
a fact pattern resulted in contractual
rescission doesn't necessarily mean a
similar fact pattern also
will or should at least not.
If we take seriously the
requirement that the court way,
what would best avoid
injustice in a given case.
Finally,
we see the importance of the way
parties allocate risk in an agreement.
If the as is clause were absent,
it seems likely that equity would
have favored the pickles is.